[Music]
anything wrong mrs ricardo
my nose itches
as the star of the groundbreaking sitcom
i love lucy
lucille ball was a comedy legend
fine you're doing splendidly speed
she was also a force in show business
the first woman to run a major hollywood
studio
and now she may get some credit for
another innovation
i'm visiting one of my favorite people
in this industry mr dick
van dyke hi lucy hi doll thanks very
much for giving me some time today
that's right long before the current
explosion in podcasting
it turns out that ball was creating
something
very similar for one year she would do
these 10 minute conversations with
friends
with stars steve battaglio is the media
reporter for the los
angeles times you didn't have the
internet you didn't have social media
your relationship with a celebrity was
what you saw on the screen
talk shows were the only place where you
saw something that resembled
what they were really like hiya lucy how
are you i'm fine you know it ain't easy
catching up with you
to have something like this it's living
history i had a cold for three weeks
i've had it since 1962 i think ah using
her own portable reel to reel
tape recorder ball sat down with some of
the biggest stars of the day
many of whom were her friends names like
frank sinatra
bob hope bing crosby mary tyler moore
dick van dyke and barbara streisand
oh all the people were clamoring around
it was so confusing and i just wanted to
be left alone
i wasn't that happy with my performance
opening night yeah
and you're a realist you're a real
wonderful realist
the intimacy of these conversations will
really
take you back to that time the
recordings ran for two years starting in
1964
as let's talk to lucy a daily 10-minute
program on the cbs radio network
and this week they'll re-emerge on
sirius
xm radio but only because they were kept
safe over the last
57 years by lucy and her husband desi's
oldest child
lucy arnez today again i have vivian
vance my adorable ethel mertz my
adorable vivian bagley
one of the show's highlights is a sit
down lucy did with her longtime
co-star vivian vance you and i have been
through a lot together we've been
through a lot lucille
that's another thing i think that's
drawn us even closer
through the years rather than the long
association driving us apart
how did lucy arnez find this
gold mine i think her mother understood
content and understood the value of
everything that she did
and i think that's why those radio
programs were saved lucy
arnez was aware of them took care of
them but she didn't know really know
what to do with them
now we have podcasting we have streaming
and she found a market for them did
anything surprise you
about the real lucy she's very tough
she's very opinionated very secure in
expressing herself
i think she knew that she was lucy and
there was everybody else
ah so she was the queen correct
you got it
[Applause]
and you get the real sense when you
listen to her voice she was no
lucy ricardo she was this full-fledged
woman with
her own set of opinions her and her the
people she interviewed
too you get a taste of who they are
unlike anything i've seen
ever what a treasure trove yeah i mean
that's what seven years later yeah so
ahead of her time
surprise oh can't i've gotta listen to
those great michelle thank you